All right.
Let me ask you about what
we're expecting to see.
You know, I was here in 20, 18
when you had a huge mudslide.
Same place, Montecito
that was devastating and deadly.
But are these storms different?
Do you see these storms in a dif
than in the past?
Well, Sara, to give you some con
over the last two
and a half weeks, we have had si
so-called atmospheric rivers
coming through our state.
About as much rainfall
has fallen on our state in two a
weeks, as would happen in a norm
Not a drought year, but a normal
The ground is saturated.
We're simply overwhelmed with wa
And we have two more major storm
set to come in starting tomorrow
So this is a very significant em
We have lost about 19 people
and about 100,000
people are currently under an ev
order.
We are looking at flood alerts
across the state, potential for
outages, mudslides, massive
amount of snow up in the mountai
So we're bracing for more and it
very difficult because when the
is so saturated, any additional
has a trigger effect of even
the potential for for more and g
flooding and mudslides
and other emergencies,
I think has been referred to
as as whiplash weather,
where you go from a drought to a
and you don't get sort of the ca
in between.
I do want to ask you about
whether you think
that this is going to be the new
for California and frankly, for
that we are going to be doing th
sort of whiplash back and forth
with deadly storms and then,
you know, really problematic dro
extreme weather in general,
if that's going to be
the thing that we're going
to all have to get used to
Yes, the answer is yes.
And in California,
we are very Science-Based in our
to problem solving.
We've known for a long time
that extreme weather is coming,
by a warming climate and climate
And we have been investing in it
in shoring up our levees
and our infrastructure, in build
what is one of the largest
and most extensive emergency
response systems anywhere in the
with helicopters and the kinds o
that can come in in the case of
but at the same time, the kind o
to mobilize for wildfires.
So we have been preparing for so
Nevertheless, the magnitude
of what we are up against in
the coming days is very severe.
And we are asking people in thei
to get ready
to get ready to evacuate if they
to watch for rising water,
to look at their local news, tap
for flashlights and to get ready
Because these swings between dro
and then the kind of
atmospheric rivers that we're se
they are here to stay.
And and again, we are wide eyed.
We are clear eyed about what
we are up against.
But as prepared as we are,
Mother
Nature has the capacity to wreak
and we are doing our best
to get ready for it.
Lieutenant Governor,
I want to ask you about getting
because if this is the new norm,
as you say, how how are you as
as one of the leaders of the sta
making sure that California is p
And when when I say that,
what are some of the things on t
or that are being done to try an
some of this
for the citizens of this state?
So for decades now, we
have been putting state money
and federal resources into build
flood control and improving our
as well as doing things
like improving the ability to st
so that when it rains,
whether it's in surface water st
or frankly, recharging our aquif
we're doing the most to take adv
of the water that is coming into
right now, while at the same tim
preventing loss of life
and being able to respond to eme
So all of this
is happening at the same time,
and we've been working on it for
So so that's all great.
But what we are also doing
and I think this is really impor
something California is known fo
because we know
that climate change is real.
We are investing in a carbon
free energy future.
So we have about $48 billion
over the last two years
in the kind of tax credits
that will allow the private sect
to come up with the kind of inno
that we hope will change
the ability of us on a global le
to be able to combat climate cha
And and deal with
or try to avoid further
climate change in the future.
Of course, that's a much bigger
But we are responding to this
from everything
from responding to extreme weath
to trying to prevent more climat
in the future by transitioning t
free energy future.
Countless California,
we have the capacity to
to have it all to deal with it
on both of these levels.
And that's what we're trying to
California is something like the
largest economy in the world.
And I want to ask you about that
because right now California
is facing a potential $22 billio
plus budget deficit.
And we've been looking at the fa
that Governor Newsom has propose
6 billion of the 54 billion
that was set aside for a multi-y
spend on on climate
that's going to be cut down
some because of the deficit pote
Why do that at a time when you k
this is going to be the new norm
and it really is needed
So last year
we had a $100 billion budget sur
and that is a big part of where
that $54,000,000,056 billion cam
in order to transition to a carb
free energy future.
Cutting it by 6 billion
is a relatively small difference
And what it did was allow us to
to tap into our rainy day fund.
So our rainy day
fund is higher than it's ever be
We feel very strongly positioned
to be able to deal with this def
but also to an economic turndown
that's happening nationwide.
So we still have enormous resour
that are going in to combating
climate change in the future.
And we encourage entrepreneurs
to take advantage of these progr
because they're mostly coming in
of tax credits and grants
to leverage innovation
for for new approaches
to everything from battery stora
and offshore wind
to developing sun and wind
as alternatives to these
to non-renewal able energy sourc
that dominate in the world today
Well, there is plenty of sun her
most of the time over the last
couple of weeks of have proven o
I do want to talk to you
about some research that was pub
by the academic journal Science.
ExxonMobil accurately forecasted
you know, how climate change was
to cause this global temperature
as long as the 1970s
according to this research
and they predicted how burning
fossil fuels would warm the plan
and but they publicly denied the
ExxonMobil has come out and said
look this issue has come up seve
in recent years.
And in each case our answer is t
those who talk about how Exxon k
were are wrong in their conclusi
But this is the research
being done by the academic journ
I'd like to know from you.
Do you think that big oil
is responsible in part
and should take part in the solu
In other words, pay up
Yes. And thank you
for bringing this
to the awareness of CNN Internat
because you have people
watching around the world.
But here in California, we have
this is happening for a very lon
That is why are 20, 45 goals in
being carbon neutral?
Our 20, 35 goal that starting in
the only new cars that can be so
California must be zero emission
The standards
that we put in place in our stat
ahead of anywhere else in the co
and almost anywhere in the world
And we are putting our money
where our mouth is and in partic
trying to leverage our dollars
with the private sector, with in
with the next generation
that considers a changing
climate to be their moonshot.
So we're moving forward into the
But at the same time, absolutely
oil companies have to be held ac
You know, in California,
we're also feeling a backlash fr
because they've jacked up our
our gas prices here beyond what
in other parts of the country
and then blame it on us.
I which was absolutely wrong and
So the future is renewable energ
And I hope that all of your view
particularly young people
and young people who are ambitio
want to make a difference in the
get on board and help because th
really where we have to go.